This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Whether or not you're a fan of math, it's undeniable that as a society, we've always had a need to count things. Maybe it's to figure out the maximum weight an airplane can safely hold, or the appropriate amount to tip after a meal, or the exact number of minutes and a year so that you can accurately write the soundtrack to the hit Broadway musical Rent. Either way, keeping track of numbers has always been a part of what makes us human.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。无论你是否喜欢数学，不可否认的是，作为一个社会，我们一直有计算事物的需求。也许是为了算出飞机安全载重的最大值，或者是在餐后计算合适的消费金额，又或者是为了准确写出百老汇热门音乐剧《吉屋出租》的配乐，而算出一年中精确的分钟数。无论如何，记录数字一直是我们人类特质的一部分。
So at some point along the way, we created a tool to help us keep count, and then we gave that tool a name. We called it a calculator. But depending on what era you were born in and maybe even what country, what constituted a calculator varied widely. In elementary school, I had a calculator watch, which I thought was the coolest thing in the world. When I visited my dad's house, I would marvel at the slide rolls that he had in his junk
所以在某个阶段，我们创造了一种工具来帮助我们计数，并给这个工具起了一个名字。我们叫它计算器。但根据你出生的时代，甚至所在的国家，计算器的定义大不相同。在小学时，我有一个计算器手表，我觉得那是世界上最酷的东西。当我拜访我父亲家时，我会惊叹于他放在杂物抽屉里的计算尺。
drawer. His father, a bookkeeper, had a monstrous metal-add-y machine in his office that I used to love to play with. And if you go back far enough to a time before written numbers even existed, a calculator was also an abacus, a tally stick, and our very own fingers and toes. Regardless of the format took, though, what's clear is this. Without the calculator, our built world, as we know it, just would not exist. You trace it all the way back and it's like, oh, the entire recorded history of humanity
他父亲是一名簿记员，办公室里有一台巨大的金属加法机，我以前很喜欢玩。如果你追溯到文字数字出现之前的时代，计算器还包括算盘、刻痕木棍，以及我们自己的手指和脚趾。然而，无论形式如何，显而易见的是：没有计算器，我们所知的建筑世界根本就不会存在。如果你一路追溯，你会发现，人类全部的文明记录史，某种程度上都是由我们必须计算事物这一事实所驱动的。这是作家基思·休斯顿。他在他的新书中详细讲述了计算器的演变。我叫基思·休斯顿，是《和之帝国：袖珍计算器的兴衰》一书的作者。那么，让我们谈谈这种计算和计数的必要性。似乎我们作为生物，总是意识到我们需要计算的数量超过了我们拥有的计算工具。让我们谈谈计数的历史起源和那种驱动力。我认为有趣的是，从某种意义上说，它没有历史起源，它实际上有一个生物学起源。事实证明，很多动物都会计数。
is kind of driven by the fact that we have to count things. This is author Keith Houston. He writes all about the evolution of the calculator in his new book. My name is Keith Houston and I am the author of Empire of the Sum, the Rise and Rain of the Pocket Calculator. Well, let's talk about this need for calculation and for counting. It seems like we, you know, as organisms seem to recognize that we always need to count more than we have the tools to count. Let's talk about, like, you know, the historical origin of counting and that drive. I think the funny thing is, in a sense, there's not a historical origin of it. There's actually a biological origin of it. It turns out that lots of animals count.
（注：原文此处有重复，已按逻辑合并）
There were a series of experiments, I think, most prominently with a parrot in, I think, it was the 20th century who was taught to count up to six. Ravens or crows apparently had previously been found to be able to count up to seven, so the parrot wasn't that impressive. But the parrot also had a concept of zero, which is incredible. The parrot understood that there was a thing which was there is nothing here to be counted. And so animals can count, insects can count, spiders are not very good, I think some spiders can manage two, and they're surprised if they see more than two things.
有一系列实验，我想最著名的是20世纪的一只鹦鹉，它被教导可以数到六。乌鸦或渡鸦显然此前被发现能够数到七，所以那只鹦鹉并不令人印象深刻。但那只鹦鹉还有一个零的概念，这太不可思议了。鹦鹉理解有一种东西，就是“这里没有什么东西可以数”。所以动物可以计数，昆虫可以计数，蜘蛛不太擅长，我想有些蜘蛛能应付两个，如果它们看到超过两个东西，它们会感到惊讶。
And humans can count. Even human babies have some innate ability to count. I think there's a sort of canonical example, which is if you show a baby some number of objects, and then you hide those objects and you take one away and you add one, or you add one, and then you reveal it again, they are surprised, they displace or prize because the number of things that they're looking at has changed. So, humans can count even before we're old enough to be able to articulate what that means. Yeah, yeah. And then, so, you know, in an effort to count, I don't know how the parrot does it, but we tend to use our fingers and toes and, you know, different parts of our bodies. You talk about that and then the process of weaning ourselves off of that limitation. There's been a bunch of different ethnographic research that shows that we almost certainly
人类也可以计数。甚至人类婴儿也有一些天生的计数能力。我想有一个典型的例子：如果你给婴儿看一定数量的物体，然后把这些物体藏起来，拿走一个或增加一个，然后再展示给他们看，他们会感到惊讶，因为他们看到的物体数量发生了变化。所以，人类甚至在我们还小到无法表达这意味着什么之前就能计数。是的，是的。那么，为了计数，我不知道鹦鹉是怎么做的，但我们倾向于使用我们的手指和脚趾，以及我们身体的不同部位。你谈到了这一点，以及我们摆脱这种局限的过程。有许多不同的民族志研究表明，我们几乎肯定是通过手指学会计数的。
learn to count using our fingers. A lot of different groups of humans at different times and in different places have had number systems kind of with linguistic bases of five or ten because of course you have you know five digits in each hand or maybe twenty because you maybe think of your fingers and your toes as being a kind of a complete set. So we've always had this ability to count with our bodies. We got really really good at finger counting. There are a bunch of clues in Sumerian writing. The Sumerians were the people who lived in Mesopotamia, a land between
许多不同的人类群体在不同的时间和地点，都有以五或十为语言基础的数字系统，因为当然，你每只手有五个手指，或者也许是二十，因为你可能认为你的手指和脚趾是一个完整的集合。所以我们一直有这种用身体计数的能力。我们非常擅长手指计数。苏美尔人的文字中有很多线索。苏美尔人是生活在美索不达米亚的人，那是古代近东底格里斯河和幼发拉底河之间的一片土地。
the Tigris and Euphrates River in the ancient Nereast. Then what seemed to happen was the Egyptians got in on this finger counting lark as well. There are some paintings that show in on this finger counting lark as well. And there are some paintings that show Egyptian merchants making interesting shapes with their hands. They won't really show what this was. And then the same thing recurs in ancient Rome. There's a statue somewhere in Rome of the god Janus. And he was said to be making signs with his hands that represented the number of days in the year. And of course, this is even more than 10. It's more than 60. Someone is counting to more than 300 using their fingers, but again, no one quite knew how. So we went a really long way with our hands. But of course, at the same time, we realized that this is not very practical. Your hands are good for recording
然后发生的事情似乎是埃及人也加入了这种手指计数的行列。有一些画作展示了埃及商人用手做出有趣的形状。他们并没有真正展示这是什么。同样的事情在古罗马也出现了。罗马某处有一座神雅努斯的雕像。据说他用手做出的手势代表了一年中的天数。当然，这甚至超过了10。它超过了60。有人用手指计数超过300，但同样，没有人确切知道是如何做到的。所以我们用手走得很远。但当然，与此同时，我们意识到这并不实用。你的手擅长记录数字，但不一定擅长操作它们，不擅长真正用它们做数学运算。这就是我们开始考虑计算设备的地方。第一个进入视野的计算设备是算盘。你可能以前见过某种版本的算盘。你知道，一个带有穿过它的金属丝行的框架。那些金属丝上串着珠子。通常每根金属丝上有10颗珠子，你可以把它想成：好吧，这颗珠子或这根金属丝代表个位，
numbers. They're not necessarily good for manipulating them, for actually doing maths with them. And that's where we start to think about calculating devices. The first such calculating device to enter the picture was the abacus. You've probably seen some version of an abacus before. You know, wouldn't frame with rows of wires cutting through it. Those wires have beads strong onto them. Typically, 10 beads per wire, and you can think of it as, OK, this bead or this wire represents the units,
这代表十位、百位、千位，以此类推。目前还不清楚算盘究竟起源于何处，但早在公元前300年，世界各地的古代文明中就出现了这种设备的版本。有一个非常隐晦的参考
this represents the tens, and the hundreds, and the thousands, and so on. It's unclear from where exactly the Abukus originated, but there are versions of this device in ancient civilizations all around the world as early as 300 BC. There's a really elliptical reference
指向中国书中所写的可能是算盘的东西。罗马和中国，我们谈论的是商人在往返于这两个超级大国之间进行交流。所以算盘的想法向一个方向或另一个方向传播是完全可能的。我不认为有人真的知道。但肯定到了这个时候，你有了算盘的概念。事实上，拉丁语中也有“算盘”这个词。中国、日本和韩国似乎真的很喜欢算盘的概念，几乎一直延续到今天，而在西方，它似乎消失了。
to what could be an Abukus in a book written in China. And Roman China were talking merchants were moving back and forth and communicating between these two sort of superpowers. So it's entirely possible that the idea for the abacus went in one direction or the other. I don't think anyone really knows. But certainly by this point, you have the concept of the abacus. You have the word abacus as well, in fact, in Latin. China and Japan and Korea seem to really love the concept of the abacus, you have the word abacus as well in fact in Latin China and Japan and Korea Seem to really love the concept of the abacus almost down to the present day, whereas it seems to kind of go away in the West
我认为真正取代算盘的工具是书写。我们习惯了所谓的印度-阿拉伯数字，因为它们源于印度和阿拉伯国家的十进制数字和位值记数法传统。所以，你知道，如果我写下数字9，它意味着某种东西；如果我写下1和9，如果我在它旁边再放一个9，那意味着99，这就是位值的部分。其中一个9代表90，另一个代表9。事实证明，这是一种非常灵活的数字书写方式。它非常适合数学。它肯定比算盘好得多。所以这就是纸笔更好的地方。
The tool the really I think that succeeded the abacus for us was writing We got used to what we call Hindu Arabic numerals because they came out of a tradition in India and in the Arab countries to use decimal numbers and a place value notation. So you know if I write down the number 9 it means something different if I just write 1 9 and if I put another 9 beside it that something means 99 that's the place value part of it. One of those nine's means 90, one of them means nine. And it turns out this is a really flexible way to write numbers. It's really good for maths. It's certainly far better than abacus. So that's where pen and paper is better.
所以人们使用纸笔。它们被称为算法（Algorithmes）。而使用算盘的人被称为算盘使用者（Abacists）。两者之间长期存在着某种竞争。当然，最终在西方，算法派胜出了。如果我们手工做数学，我们不使用算盘，我们用纸上的钢笔或铅笔。听起来作为算法派，使用纸笔和位值系统的一个关键优势是，你可以把计算过程记录在脑子之外。
So people use pen and paper. It were called algorithms. And the people who use abacuses were called abacus. And there was a bit of a sort of a rivalry between the two of them for quite a long time. And eventually, of course, in the West, the Algorithtes came out on top. If we're doing maths by hand, we're not using an abacus, we're dealing with a pen or a pencil on a piece of paper. It sounds like one of the key advantages of being an algorithm, using a pen and paper and a place value system is that you could keep track of your calculations outside of your own head.
是的，是的，绝对是。你可以展示你的计算过程。你提到算盘有着悠久而传奇的演变，但当你谈到书中的这些计数设备和计算器时，有时为了达到新的形式，会有一种完全的形态抹除。你知道，这与许多其他物理对象的演变方式不同。是的。每种计算设备之间确实存在真正的阶梯式变化。我认为这可能就是它们彼此如此不同的原因。你从计数板和算盘开始。在西方，我们转向了纸笔。
Yes, yes, definitely. You can show your working. You mentioned, you know, the abacus has a long and storied evolution, but when it comes to these counting devices and calculators that you talk about in your book, there's also this kind of like a complete obliteration of form sometimes and to get to the new one. You know, like in a way that's kind of unlike a lot of other sort of, you know, physical object evolution. Yes. There's definitely a real step change between each sort of class of calculating devices. And I think that is probably the reason why there's so different to one another. You start off with counting boards and abacuses. And in the West we move towards pen and paper. and why they're so different to one another. You start off with counting boards and abacuses,
而在西方，我们转向了纸笔。然后下一个重大的创新是所谓的计算尺。计算尺是17世纪出现的一项重大创新。它看起来有点像它听起来的样子。它就像你普通的尺子，通常不超过12英寸，上面标有许多数字，
and in the west we move towards pen and paper. And then really the next big innovation is a thing called the slide rule. The slide rule was a major innovation that came along in the 1600s. It looks a bit like how it sounds. It's like your average ruler, often no longer than 12 inches, marked with lots of numbers and a quick,
带有一个滑动机制。计算尺的诞生是因为一项新发现的出现，即“对数”。对数基本上是一种花哨的度量，它使大数字相乘变得容易得多，但还没有容易到你可以在脑子里完成。所以在计算尺之前，我们必须使用这些被称为对数表的长图表来计算对数。所以计算尺背后的基础是这些非常非常长的、极其精确的对数表书籍。你会查一个数字，查另一个，把两个数字加起来，查第三个，你就把它们乘起来了。
with a sliding mechanism. The slide rule was created because a new discovery had come along, something called the log rhythm. Log rhythms are basically this fancy metric that makes multiplying big numbers together a lot easier, but not so much easier that you can do it in your head. So prior to the slide rule, we had to calculate logs using these long charts known as log tables. So that basis behind the slide rule were these very, very long books of incredibly accurate logarithmic tables. And you'd look one number up, look another one up, add the two numbers together, look up the third one, and you've multiplied them.
而计算尺只是那种物理上的化身。这就是为什么它有不同的物理形式。计算尺使计算比使用对数表和纸笔快得多，且更不容易出错。它感觉就像魔法。这是一件不可思议的事情，因为用纸笔做乘法可能是一件非常痛苦的事情。我作为一个物体对计算尺有一种偏爱。我父亲获得了数学学位，我记得在他家周围见过计算尺。这个看起来很酷，但又微小而谦逊的工具，
And the slide rule was just a kind of physical incarnation of that. So that's why it had a different physical form. The slide rule made calculations a lot faster and less error-prone than using the log charts and pen and paper. It feels like magic. It is this incredible thing because multiplication can be such a pain in the neck with pen and paper. I have a fondness for the slide rule as an object. My father graduated with a degree in mathematics, and I remember seeing slide rules around his house. And this very cool looking, but tiny and humble tool,
是世纪中期工程学的基础。我的意思是，它被用来把阿波罗11号送上月球。它被用来设计飞机。它被用来建造火箭。我必须承认，如果你不知道怎么用，它看起来确实有点复杂和令人生畏。所以我试着描述一下如何使用计算尺。它不是一个适合广播的工具。
was the basis of mid-century engineering. I mean, it was used to get the Apollo 11 to the moon. It was used to design airplanes. It was used to build rockets. And I have to admit, it does look a little complicated and daunting if you don't know how to use it. So I'll have a crack at describing how to use a slide drill. It's not a tool for radio.
因为它是像尺子一样，因为它有两个可移动的部分，或者这两个部分相对于彼此移动，你必须对齐它们。你必须看几个数字，确保它们尽可能精确地对齐，然后你需要查找结果。所以想象一下，尽可能仔细地盯着一把普通的12英寸或30厘米的尺子，以弄清楚某样东西到底有多长。最终你会达到测量对象位于两条线之间的程度。
So because it's like a ruler and because it has these two movable sections or these two sections that move relative to one another, you have to align them. You have to look at a couple of numbers, make sure they're aligned as precisely as you can and then you need to look up a result. And so imagine peering at a normal 12-inch or 30-centimeter ruler as closely as you can to figure out exactly where how long something is. And eventually get to the point where the thing that you're measuring lies between two lines.
所以你只需要猜测，好吧，是12.252厘米还是12.253厘米，或者无论是什么数字，你必须开始估算，它们不是超级精确的。这正是让我着迷和困惑的地方。当你使用计算尺时，在某一点上，你本质上需要估算你的结果。这是我们用来帮助塑造我们如此多建筑环境的工具，然而它在设计上本质上是不精确的，就像你进行测量，你必须在某一点上目测，我很好奇这可能如何塑造了我们的建筑环境。
And so you just have to guess, okay, is it 12 guess okay is it you know is it 12.252 centimeters or is it 12.253 centimeters or whatever number it is you have to you have to start estimating it they're not super accurate. And this is what fascinates and confounds me. It's that when you use a slide rule at a a certain point, you're essentially needing to estimate your result. It's this tool that we've used to help shape so much of our built environment, and yet it's inherently kind of imprecise by design, like you make a measurement, and you just have to eyeball it at a certain point, and I'm curious how that might have shaped our built environment.
从根本上说，如果你要用计算尺进行大量计算，一切都必须是线性的，我的意思是，大多数方程只需要是乘法或除法，或者只是加上某个常数。这意味着人们确实有动力去简化许多控制建筑建造或飞机设计方式的方程。我似乎记得我在大学学习物理时，不幸的是，我不是一个很好的物理学家。我的一位老师是空气动力学家，那是他的专长。我记得我完全被难住了，因为空气动力学太难了。
Fundamentally, if you're going to be doing a lot of calculations with a slide rule, everything has to be linear, by which, I mean, most equations need to just be multiplications or divisions or just adding some constant number. And so this meant there was a real drive towards simplifying a lot of the equations that governed how, for example, buildings were built or planes were designed. I seem to remember that university where I studied physics wasn't a very good physicist, unfortunately. One of my teachers was an aerodynamicist, that was his thing. And I remember being absolutely flummoxed because aerodynamics was so hard.
有很多立方和平方根，以及更复杂的、更高阶的方程。这意味着如果你只有一把计算尺，你必须简化它，你必须对你正在做的更复杂的事情提出某种近似，这样你才有能力用它做足够的计算，使其产生影响。所以我们最终得到的世界里，桥梁比需要的更坚固，建筑物比需要的更矮、更结实。汽车效率较低，飞机效率较低，
There are lots of cubes and square roots and much more complicated, it's of higher order equations. And this means that if all you have is a slide drill, you have to simplify it, you have to come up with some approximation to the much more complicated thing you're doing, such that you have the ability to do enough calculations with it for it to matter. And so we ended up with a kind of world where bridges were stronger than they had to be, and buildings were squatter and stronger than they had to be. Cars were less efficient, planes were less efficient,
所有这些都是因为计算尺简化并减少了我们能处理的复杂性。它迫使我们以一种更简单的方式看待问题，因为这是进行大量计算的唯一实用方法。当你意识到你没有你应有的那么精确时，你就会倾向于让飞机更重，让墙壁更宽。是的，这是一种确切的事情。是的。这让我感到惊奇。然后有一个特定的点。作为一个社会，我们的数学变得越来越复杂。我们也有一种更高效、计算更快的渴望。那么这里开始形成什么样的变化呢？所以计算器，我们可能认为是计算器的东西，
all because the slide rule just simplified and reduced the set of complexity we could address. It forced us to look at problems in a simpler way, because it was the only practical way to do huge amounts of calculation. And when you know that you're not as precise as you should be, you err on the side of making planes heavier, making walls wider. Yeah, that's sort of an exact thing. Yes. That's amazing to me. And then there's a certain point. As a society, our math was getting more and more complicated. We also had this desire to be more efficient and calculate faster. So what changes start to take shape here? So the calculator, the thing that we might recognize as a calculator,
必须有一种不同的形式，因为计算尺的形式不行，纸笔也不行。你在做什么？你在操作错误的数字。你输入一些数字。你执行一些操作。然后你输入更多的数字并执行另一个操作，以此类推。在那之后。所以我认为计算器的形式必须改变以适应这一点。当然，这就是机械计算器出现的地方，你开始看到一些东西，它们看起来不像现代计算器，但它们在某种程度上确实像它们一样运作。那些早期的机械计算器又大又笨重。其中一些听起来很像打字机。这是1941年制造的Olavetti Summa MC3的声音。它的名字有点拗口，而且它的尺寸有点难以驾驭。事实上，是很多大的难以驾驭。一路上开发的最早、也许是最古怪的机械计算器之一被称为Curta。它是由一个叫库尔特·赫兹斯塔克的人在1945年设计的。
kind of has to have a different form because the slide rules form isn't cutting it, pen and paper isn't cutting it. What are you doing? You're manipulating the wrong numbers. You're entering some numbers. You're carrying out some operation. And then you are entering some more numbers and carrying out another operation and so on. After that. So I think the form of a calculator kind of had to change to accommodate that. And of course, this is where mathematical,
它的形状和大小像一个胡椒研磨机。Curta，威廉·吉布森在他的一部小说中称它为“数学手榴弹”。它是一个情节装置，它是一个……一个麦格芬（推动剧情的物件）。它看起来像……它看起来像一个带有许多滑块的罐头。Curta是第一台数字袖珍计算器。它可以放在你的手掌里，并以其不寻常的圆柱形形状而闻名。它的形状是因为它是由一个非常特殊的机械结构驱动的，
this is where mechanical calculators come along and you start to see things that they don't look like modern calculators, but they do in some way function like them. Those early mechanical calculators were large and clunky. Some of them sounded a lot like a typewriter. This is the sound of an Olavetti simply CCMA, MC3, made in 1941. Its name is a bit of a mouthful, and its size is a bit of a handful. Many large handfuls, in fact. One of the earliest and maybe wackiest mechanical calculators developed along the way was called the curta. It was designed in 1945 by a guy named Kurt Herzark.
称为阶梯鼓。这是一件极其巧妙的包装。这意味着有可能拥有一台真正袖珍的计算器，可以非常可靠地进行加减法。我的意思是，它的由来故事，我认为和任何其他事情一样有趣。它是由一个叫库尔特·赫兹斯塔克的奥地利人开发的，他最终被关押在
It was the shape and size of a pepper grinder. The curta, William Gibson called it a math grenade in one of his novels. It's a plot device, it's, you know, a... a McGuffin. And it looks like... it looks like a coat can with a bunch of sliders on the side. The curta was the first digital pocket calculator. It could fit in the palm of your hand and it was known for its unusual cylindrical shape. And it was the shape because it was driven by a very particular mechanical construct
布痕瓦尔德，那个第二次世界大战中可怕的集中营。他的俘虏给了他一个机会，如果他设计——他们不知何故知道他在被捕前是一名计算器设计师或制造者。他们说，如果你能设计这个，如果你能制造这个，我们将把这个交给未来。也许他会认为赦免你或给予你自由是合适的。所以它有这样一个可怕的背景故事，
called a stepped drum. And it's an incredibly clever piece of packaging. And it meant there was possible to have a genuinely pocket-sized calculator that could add and subtract really reliably. I mean, the story, how it came to be, I think, is interesting as anything else. It was developed by an Austrian called Kurt Herzstark, who ended up being interned in
这使得它存在并且是机械设计的瑰宝这一事实，真的很奇怪。我发现很难同时在脑海中保持这两个想法。我们之后还有更多的计算器，但首先我们需要加算一些广告费。那么，为什么我不谈谈你描述的1946年在东京发生的一件特定事件呢？那里发生了什么？
bookenwald in this horrific concentration camp in the Second World War. And he was offered a chance by his captors, if he designed, they somehow knew that he had been a calculator designer or maker before he'd been arrested. And they said, if you can design this and you can make this, we will give this to the future. And perhaps he will see fit to pardon you or to grant you freedom. So as this horrible backstory to it,
这是一个不可思议的事件。美国陆军报纸《星条旗报》在日本，战后的日本，组织了一场比赛，参赛者是一名美国陆军列兵，我想是这样，和一名日本邮局的员工。如果我没记错的话，他的名字叫松崎清（Kuyoshi Matsuzaki）。我想他的绰号是……这就是他参加比赛的部分原因。
that makes the fact that it exists and is such a gem of mechanical design, it's really weird. I find it quite hard to hold those two ideas in my head at the same time. We have more calculators after this, but first we need to add up some ad money. So why don't I talk about one particular event that you described taking place in 1946 in Tokyo? What happened there?
比赛是在日本算盘和美国新开发的尖端机械计算器之间进行的，基本上是为了看看哪一个更好。两位竞争者都被认为是各自工具的大师。松崎在邮局的工作中每天都使用他的算盘，而汤姆在美军财务部门工作。他们必须做一组加法、一组乘法、一组除法和一组减法。比赛规则是谁能最快完成。
This is an incredible event. The US Army newspaper, which is called Stars and Stripes, set up this contest in Japan, post-war in Japan, between a private in the US Army, I think it was, and an employee of the Japanese post office effectively. His name was, if I remember rightly, Kuyoshi, the hands, Matsuzaki. I imagine his nickname was, that's part of the reason he was in the contest.
汤姆·伍德的计算器是一件奢侈品。它很大，由电机驱动，转动内部齿轮。它的价格可能堪比一辆汽车。而松崎的手持算盘背后的技术大约有2000年的历史。旧的对阵新的。古老的算盘大约有2000年的历史。松崎赢了4场中的3场。我想他没赢的那场是乘法。他获胜的原因是他某种程度上内化了
The contest was between the Japanese abacus and a newly developed state of the art mechanical calculator from the US to basically see which one was better. Both competitors were considered masters of their respective tools. Matsuzaki used his Advocates every day in his job at the Postal Service, and Tom would work in the finance department of the US Army. They had to do a set of additions, a set of multiplications, a set of divisions, and a set of subtractions. And the contest was whoever could finish them most quickly.
所有你可以用算盘做的捷径。这是一种特殊的技能。所以那场比赛非常非常令人兴奋。竞争报纸以夸张的言论做出反应，比如“机器时代倒退了一步，文明摇摇欲坠，因为2000年的算盘击败了电动计算机器”。但这场比赛也为新的计算器制造商提供了灵感，推动了最终成为袖珍计算器的演变。事实上，连锁反应之一，
Tom Woods calculator was a luxury item. It was large and was powered by motors, turning internal gears. It probably rivaled the price of a car. And the technology behind Matsuzaki's handheld abacus was about 2,000 years old. Old versus the new. The ancient abacus doing about 2,000 years old. Matt Suzuki won 3 out of 4. I think the one that he didn't win was the multiplication. And the reason that he won was because he kind of internalized
是卡西欧，这家日本计算器制造商，就是从这之后开始的。这是……卡西欧是由一群兄弟创立的，其中一个叫樫尾忠雄（Toshio Casio）。忠雄读到了这场特定的比赛，他并没有作为一个爱国的日本人为松崎获胜而欢呼，他反而对这台输掉比赛的机械或电动计算器更感兴趣，他想：我想制造这些。有趣的是，当时卡西欧公司最畅销的产品是一个带有香烟架的手指环，这样你就可以在工作时，或者在洗澡时抽烟。他想，好吧，我们要制造一台计算器。但日本没有制造这些机电计算器的工业基础。他们没有足够的机械来以足够的精度制造它们。这一局限性让位于计算器的一项新技术发展。卡西欧兄弟决定用一种叫电磁阀的装置来制造他们的卡西欧计算器。所以电磁阀基本上是电磁铁内部的一个金属柱塞，
all of these shortcuts that you could do with the abacus. It was, you know, there was a special skill. And so there was great, great excitement at this contest. Ever the competition newspapers reacted with melodramatic statements like, the machine age took a step backward, and civilization has tottered as the 2000 year old Abacus beat the electric calculating machine. But the competition also served as inspiration for new calculator manufacturers to push forward the evolution of what would eventually become the pocket calculator. And in fact, one of the knock-on effects come, the pocket calculator. And in fact, one of the knock on effects
也就是绕着它的一圈线圈。如果你给那个线圈通电，柱塞就会在里面射出。所以你可以用它们来锁门，我想汽车启动电机里也有电磁阀等等。他用电磁阀和开关制造了一台计算器。所以每次你输入一个数字，某个电磁阀就会移动，这导致另一个开关关闭，计算器内部会发生连锁反应来设置数字。这一切都与早期计算有关。这就是我发现它开始变得非常有趣的地方，因为计算器正在做的是计算机在小规模上做的事情，在一个普通人有机会购买计算
was that Casio, the Japanese calculator manufacturer, got started off the back of this. This was, Casio was started by a group of brothers, one of them who's called Toshio Casio. Toshio had read about this particular contest, and rather than being a patriotic Japanese person and sort of cheering Matt Tazaki for winning, he was more interested in this mechanical or this electrical,
设备，一个我们第一次在人类历史上理解意义上的数字二进制计算设备的规模上。在那之前的一切都是十进制的，是齿轮，是旋转的齿轮和凸轮等等。第一台卡西欧计算器，14A，大约有书桌那么大，当你输入数字让它计算结果时，它会发出咔哒声。但我认为，这就是世界上第一种可获得的数字计算设备。现代计算器就是从那时开始存在的。世界上最新、最快、最令人惊叹的电子计算器在纽约进行了测试。
electro-mechanical calculator which had lost the contest and he thought I want to make these. And the funny thing was at the time, the Casio company, the biggest selling product was a finger ring with a cigarette holder on it so that you could smoke a cigarette at work or, you know, in the bath. And he thought, okay, we're going to build a calculator. But Japan didn't have the industrial base to make these electro-mechanical calculators. They didn't have enough machinery to build them with sufficient precision. That limitation gave way to a new technological development in calculators. The Cascio Brothers decided to build their Cascio calculators off a device called a solenoid. So solenoid is basically a metal sort of plunger inside an electromagnet,
它每秒可以进行2000多次乘除法，每秒进行16000多次加减法。在一名操作员的监督下，像这样的问题，如果一个人用台式计算机工作可能需要七年，现在在七分钟内就解决了。那么你如何把这台书桌大小的机电计算器做得更小呢？当你这样做时会发生什么？事实证明，托马斯·爱迪生实际上发现了一件可以让这成为可能的事情，
so just a coil of wire that runs around it. And if you energize that coil of wire, the plunger shoots along inside it. And so you can use them to lock doors and I think car starter motors have got solenoids in them and so on. And he built a calculator out of solenoids and the actor switches. So every time you typed in a digit, some solenoid would move and that caused another switch to close and there would be a cascade throughout the calculator to set the number. And this all relates back to early computing. And this is where I find it starts to get really interesting because what calculators are doing is what computers are doing on a small scale, on a scale where the average person would have the chance to buy a computing
规模要大得多。你可以制造更大或更快、更小的计算机。他发现了所谓的“爱迪生效应”，电子会穿过灯泡内部没有空气的空旷空间。他发现了这个效应，但他并没有真正用它做什么。但其他人，在他之后，弄清楚了他们如何能把这些灯泡变成放大器。所以我有一个强电流，我有一个正在变化的弱电流，我可以调制强电流，使其与弱电流匹配，这只是一个放大器。
device, a digital binary computing device in a sense that we understand it for the first time in human history. Everything up to that point had been decimal, it had been gears, it had been rotating gears and cams and so on. And the very first Casio calculator, the 14A, was about the size of a desk and it chattered away as you type to numbers and for it to compute the result. But this was the first kind of attainable digital calculating device that the world had ever seen. That's when the modern calculator comes into existence, I think. The world's newest and fastest and most amazing electronic calculator gets a workout in New York.
所以，我可以放大音频信号，例如，或者我可以放大电话通话。人们在此基础上发展，发现你可以使用真空管作为制造计算机的基础。当然，还有计算器。这些微小的管子意味着计算器可以比以往任何时候都做得更小。他们着手制造一台电子计算器，一台比他之前制造的那些机械计算器更快、更灵活的计算器。所以他们雇了一个曾在英国早期计算工作中工作过的人，他说我们要在计算器里使用真空管。它被称为Anita。它大约有收银机那么大，里面有数百个这种小管子。YouTube上某处有一个精彩的视频，
It can multiply and divide more than 2,000 times a second and add and subtract 16,000 times a second. Supervised by a single operator, problems like this that might take a person working with a desk computer seven years, now are solved in seven minutes. And so how do you take this electro-mechanical calculator that's, you know, desk sized and make it smaller? What happens when you do that? It turns out that Thomas Edison had actually discovered a thing that would make this possible
是关于拆掉外壳的Anita。当有人输入数字时，你会看到这些小真空管亮起并闪烁。就像机器内部飞来飞去的小萤火虫。Anita只是一大堆连接在一起的电气开关。这就是驱动计算器演变的原因。
at a much larger scale. You could build larger or you could build faster, smaller computers. He had discovered this thing called the Edison effect, where electrons would cross the empty space inside a bulb with no air inside it. And he kind of discovered this, he discovered this effect, and he didn't really do anything with it. But others, Koukeh, after him, figured out how they could turn these bulbs into amplifiers. So I've got one strong current, and I've got a weaker current that's changing, and I can modulate the strong current, so it matches the weaker current, which is just an amplifier.
接下来出现的是晶体管。所以在美国的贝尔实验室，他们开发了一种基本上可以由一小块硅或锗制成的微型放大器，所以你可以把这些东西做得非常小。人们开始用晶体管制造计算器，因为它们只是更多的开关。真空管是开关，晶体管是开关。所以现在他们制造这些完全固态的计算器，它们只是装满电线的拳头大小的东西。里面全是电路板。
So, you know, I can amplify an audio signal, for example, or I can amplify a telephone call. People built on this development and discovered that you could use vacuum tubes as the basis for building computers. And of course, calculators. These tiny little tubes meant that calculators could be built smaller than ever before. They set out to build an electronic calculator, one that would be much faster and more flexible than these mechanical ones he'd been making previously. And so they hired a guy who'd worked on some of Britain's earliest computing efforts, and he said we are going to use vacuum tubes inside our calculator. It was called the Anita. It's about the size of a cash register, and inside it had hundreds of these little tubes. There's a fantastic video somewhere on YouTube
所有这些组件都是手动连接的。下一步是集成电路。德州仪器的一个叫杰克·基尔比（Jack Kilby）的人发现，当我们把所有这些晶体管制造在单独的硅或锗片上时，我们为什么不能把它们全部制造在一块上，然后把它们连接在那一小块硅上呢？所以这就是可以说是有史以来第一台真正的袖珍计算器的来源。到1972年，有数百家计算器公司开发了数千种不同型号的
of an Anita with the case taken off. And as someone types the numbers, you see these little vacuum tubes light up and flicker. It's like little fireflies darting around on the inside of the machine. The Anita was just a huge set of electrical switches wired together. And this is what drives the evolution of the calculator.
袖珍计算器，都在争夺市场上的头把交椅。那一年售出了500万台计算器，平均每台约300美元。这一时期最成功的公司之一是德州仪器（TI）。TI及其计算器系列有着巨大的统治力，尽管它们不是第一个，也不是最便宜的，也不是最小的，
The next thing to come along is the transistor. So in Bell Labs in the States, they develop basically a tiny amplifier that can be made out of a single spec of silicon or germanium, so you can make these things very small. And people start making calculators out of transistors because they're just more switches. Vacuum tubes were switches, transistors are switches. And so now they make these completely solid state calculators, which are just fist tuned with wires. It's just circuit board after circuit board on the inside.
也不是最高效的。TI计算器的崛起是计算器之前演变步骤的一个有趣的偏差，因为大多数这些发展是由公司需要开发自己的系统来计算收益，或者需要新工具、更强大工具的数学进展所驱动的。在这种情况下，TI发明了微芯片，他们想出制造和销售计算器的想法，真的只是为了销售他们的微芯片。绝对是。他们想出了一个解决方案，并正在寻找一个问题来解决。所以德州仪器通过向美国军方，特别是核导弹项目销售微芯片赚了很多钱。所以中西部地区点缀着导弹的所有那些发射井。它们内部会有很多TI芯片来运行程序。
All of these components manually wired up. And the next step is the integrated circuit. Someone at Texas Instruments, a guy called Jack Kilby, figured out that while we're making all of these transistors on separate bits of silicon or germanium, where we could just make them all in a single bit and then wire them up on this tiny little bit of silicon? And so that was where arguably the first ever honest to god pocket calculator came from. By 1972 there were hundreds of calculator companies developing thousands of different models of
但一旦你建造了你的末日导弹舰队，你就不需要更多的微芯片了，或者至少你不需要那么多。TI发现它从军方获得的合同没那么多了。所以他们想扩展业务。他们面临的问题是：我们有制造微芯片的能力，但我们需要一个市场。所以，总裁赫加蒂（Hegarty）和发明微芯片的杰克·基尔比在飞机上。
pocket calculators, all divine for that top spot in the market. Five million calculators sold that year, averaging about $300 a pop. One of the most successful companies that came out of this period was Texas Instruments. TI and their line of calculators had a massive rain, even though they weren't the first, or the cheapest, or the smallest weren't the first or the cheapest or the smallest or the most efficient. And the rise of the TI calculator is an interesting sort of deviation from the previous evolutionary steps of the calculator, whereas most of these developments were driven by a company's
当他们降落时，他们决定我们要制造一台袖珍计算器。这就是我们要销售更多微芯片的方式。任何美国学童都知道TI计算器在教室里随处可见。但有趣的是，他们起初并不想制造计算器。所以他们为它们设计了芯片。
need to develop their own system to count their proceeds or a mathematical progression that necessitated a new tool, a more powerful tool. In this case, TI had invented the microchip and they came up with the idea to make and sell calculators really just as a way to sell their microchips. Absolutely. They came up with a solution and we're looking for a problem to solve with it. So Texas Instruments had made a lot of money by selling microchips to the US military, and in particular to the nuclear missile program. So all of those silos dotted across the Midwest with the missiles in them. They would have lots of TI chips sitting inside them in order to run the show.
他们算出它将有一个打印机，而不是显示屏，因为在那个时候，LED显示屏太耗电了。它们耗尽了电池太快。所以它有一个微小的固态打印机，相当巧妙的套件。他们对佳能说，我们设计了实际上是袖珍计算器的东西。
But once you've built your fleet of doomsday missiles, you don't need any more microchips, or at least you don't need as many of them. And TI found that it just wasn't getting as many contracts from the military. So they wanted to branch out. They had a problem of, we have the ability to make microchips, but we need a market for it. And so, heggarty, the president and Jack Kilby, the guy who'd invented the microchip in the first place, were on a plane.
它并不是真的。它像……我想它有几磅重。也许是厚大衣口袋里的东西。他们把设计给了佳能，佳能把它带到……他们设计了一个生产版本。TI实际上无法足够快地生产芯片。他们在生产技术上还没有完全达到要求。
And by the time they landed, they decided that we are going to build a pocket calculator. And that is how we're going to sell more microchips. Any American school child will know that T.I. calculators are just everywhere in the classroom. But the funny thing was, they didn't want to make the calculators at first. So they designed the chips for them.
当被称为Canon Pocketronic的产品问世时，其他非常小的计算器已经赶上来了。事实上，另一家日本公司Buzzycom发布了一台计算器，它基本上只有香烟盒大小，这绝对是第一台袖珍计算器，无可争议。当然，德州仪器最终开发了
They figured out that it's going to have a printer, rather than a display, because at that point, LED displays were too power-hungry. They drained the chips for them. They figured out that it's going to have a printer rather than a display because at that point, LED displays were too power-hungry. They drained the batteries too quickly. So it had a tiny little solid state printer, quite clever piece of kit. And they said to Canon, we've designed what is effectively a pocket calculator.
TI-83图形计算器，它仍然在各地的教室里使用。那是怎么发生的？他们是如何从仅仅试图想出一种销售微芯片的新方法，变成几十年后，拥有TI计算器通常成为一种要求，老师告诉你必须买一个的？
It wasn't really. It was like, I think it was a couple of pounds in weight. Maybe a pocket on a heavy overcoat or something. And they gave Canon the design, Canon brought it to, you know, because a couple of pounds in weight, maybe a pocket on a heavy overcoat or something. And they gave Canon the design, Canon brought it to, they designed a production version of it. T.I. couldn't actually produce the chips fast enough. They still weren't quite there with their production techniques.
是的。据我所知，TI开始制造越来越多的计算器组件。他们变得非常擅长。他们似乎也非常擅长游说。所以TI有相对较大的游说预算，他们喜欢确保他们的计算器是必需的。部分地，他们会游说实际的立法者。曾经有一次尝试将其写入法律，在德克萨斯州，所有学生都必须修一门特定的高级数学课程，那种你可能需要TI图形计算器才能完成的高级数学课程。他们没能让那个法案通过。
And by the time the Canon Pochotronic, as it was called, came out, other very small calculators that are already caught up. In fact, another Japanese company called Buzzycom had released a calculator which was basically the size of packet of cigarettes, which was the absolute first pocket calculator, incontrovertibly. Of course, Texas Instruments eventually developed
等到被称为佳能Pochotronic的产品问世时，其他非常小的计算器已经赶上来了。事实上，另一家名为Buzzycom的日本公司发布了一款基本上只有香烟盒大小的计算器，这无疑是绝对意义上的第一款袖珍计算器。当然，德州仪器最终开发出了
the TI-83 graving calculator, which is still in classrooms everywhere. How did that happen? How did they go from a place where they're just trying to come up with a new way to sell their microchips to a couple of decades later, where having a TI calculator is often a requirement where a teacher tells you you have to buy one.
TI-83图形计算器，它至今仍遍布各地的教室。这是怎么发生的？他们是如何从仅仅试图寻找一种销售微芯片的新方法，发展到几十年后，拥有TI计算器往往成为老师要求学生必须购买的必备品？
Yeah. As I understand it, TI started to make more and more components of calculators. And they become quite good at it. They also seem to be quite good at lobbying. So TI had a relatively large lobbying budget and they like to make sure that their calculators were required. Partly, they would lobby actual lawmakers. There was an attempt to have it written into law partly they would lobby actual law makers. There was an attempt to have it written into law in Texas that all students had to take one particular advanced math course, the kind of advanced math course that you might need a TI graphing calculator to complete. They didn't manage to get that passed,
是的。据我了解，TI开始制造越来越多的计算器组件，并且做得相当出色。他们似乎也非常擅长游说。因此，TI拥有相对庞大的游说预算，他们喜欢确保自己的计算器成为必需品。在某种程度上，他们会游说实际的立法者。曾有人试图将此写入德克萨斯州的法律，要求所有学生都必须修读某一特定的高等数学课程，即那种可能需要TI图形计算器才能完成的高等数学课程。他们没能通过这项法案，
but they did partner with textbook manufacturers so that when you got your maths textbook, there would be a picture of a TI calculator in it. And the steps of the solution to the problem would be using a TI calculator. They also started teaching teachers, which is a very clever thing to do if you want to get pupils doing something. So a couple of teachers at Ohio State University had been quite early to realize that calculators
但他们确实与教科书制造商建立了合作关系，这样当你拿到数学课本时，里面就会有德州仪器（TI）计算器的图片。解决问题的步骤也会使用德州仪器的计算器。他们还开始培训教师，如果你想让学生做某事，这是一种非常聪明的做法。因此，俄亥俄州立大学的几位老师很早就意识到计算器
could help students who otherwise found maths quite hard. If you put a calculator in front of a kid who's been discouraged for so long, then it takes away some of the pressure. It becomes almost something to focus on. And it makes it easier for them. You don't need to worry so much about addition and subtraction and multiplication and division. They can focus on more complex concepts. And so T.I. eventually started employing these two guys to run a teacher training program that, of course, used Texas product, Texas Instruments products
可以帮助那些觉得数学很难的学生。如果你把计算器放在一个长期受挫的孩子面前，它就能减轻一些压力。它几乎成了某种可以专注的东西，也让事情变得更容易。你不需要太担心加减乘除，他们可以专注于更复杂的概念。因此，德州仪器最终开始聘请这两个人来开展教师培训项目，当然，这些项目使用的是德州仪器的产品，
to say this is how you teach this particular course. That's how you teach that particular course. And so you had this perfect storm where textbooks showed you TI calculators. Your teacher had been taught by TI how to teach the course. And I think this is why TI ended up with such a dominant position in the states to be fair. In the rest of the world, I think it's different. In the UK, for example, it was pretty much Casio Calculators. It was all Casio Calculators. But my wife was American very clearly remembers
来传授如何教授这门特定的课程。这就是你教授那门特定课程的方法。于是，你就有了一场完美的风暴：教科书向你展示德州仪器的计算器，你的老师也接受过德州仪器的教学培训。公平地说，我认为这就是德州仪器最终在美国占据如此主导地位的原因。在世界其他地方，我认为情况有所不同。例如，在英国，几乎全是卡西欧计算器。全是卡西欧计算器。但我妻子是美国人，她非常清楚地记得
the TI 83 that she had to use at high school. Yeah. And so during this time, I mean, was there any kind of pushback or resistance to the infiltration of electronic calculators in the classroom? Yes, there was this panic. In the same way that the Egyptians had panicked that they were going to forget about things when they were given writing, you know, 5,000 years ago,
她在高中时必须使用的 TI-83。是的。那么在这段时间里，对于电子计算器渗入课堂，是否有任何抵制或阻力？是的，确实存在这种恐慌。就像 5000 年前埃及人被赋予文字时，曾恐慌他们会忘记事情一样，
there was a whole swath of people in the US, in particular, who were worried that kids were not going to learn the right sort of maths. Because all of their parents had learned laboriously how to add and subtract and multiply and divide, I think they thought their kids had to learn the same things. Even if that meant holding them back from more abstract or interesting concepts. It seems like there's always the sentiment, you know, the kids today kind of sentiment. That should learn how to do things the way we did things. They did this about new math when my kids were little.
在美国，有一大群人特别担心孩子们学不到正确的数学。因为他们的父母都是辛苦地学习加减乘除，我想他们认为自己的孩子也必须学习同样的东西。即使这意味着阻碍他们接触更抽象或更有趣的概念。似乎总有一种“现在的孩子”这种情绪。认为他们应该像我们一样学习做事。当我的孩子们还小的时候，他们对“新数学”也持这种态度。
And I felt that my kids had a better innate sense of how numbers worked than I did in the way that I wrote memorized, how to manipulate numbers. But could you talk about the sunset of the pocket calculator, like where it's persisting and stubbornly hanging on, but also what it means as a symbol today? I think in some ways, TI's hold on calculators in the States, or at least the classroom market, is sort of, it's almost the last gas, but it's a bit of an outlier because calculators almost everywhere else have disappeared. My opinion is that when the home computer came along and when VisiCalc, which is the very
我觉得我的孩子们比我更有数字感，而我只是死记硬背如何操作数字。但你能谈谈袖珍计算器的日落吗？比如它在哪些地方顽固地坚持着，以及它今天作为一种象征意味着什么？我认为在某些方面，德州仪器在美国计算器市场，或者至少在课堂市场的统治地位，算是一种回光返照，但它有点像个异类，因为计算器在几乎其他所有地方都已经消失了。我的观点是，当家用电脑出现，当 VisiCalc（这是第一个
first computer I spreadsheet came along, it suddenly became possible not just to do simple calculations on your computer, which was something that had been possible since the very earliest computers, but it was possible to do really complicated calculations over and over again and to play around with, well, what if we take this mortgage and go for this interest rate, what does that cost us, what if we charge this amount for this particular product and we sell this much? It became possible to answer all these what if questions that previously had been just a pain in the neck. And so the spreadsheet, I think, becomes the tool of choice for people who are really serious about these large complex ongoing calculations. And so the calculator gets pushed out that way. And then it just kind of
电脑电子表格软件）出现时，突然之间，不仅可以在电脑上进行简单的计算（这在最早的电脑上就已经可以实现了），而且可以一遍又一遍地进行非常复杂的计算，并尝试各种假设，比如“如果我们采用这个抵押贷款利率，成本是多少？”“如果我们对这个特定产品收取这个价格，销量是多少？”回答所有这些以前让人头疼的“如果”问题变得可能。因此，我认为电子表格成为了那些真正认真对待这些大型、复杂、持续计算的人的首选工具。计算器就这样被挤出了市场。然后它就从
goes from everywhere else. I mean, you know, if your cash register adds up the total, do you need a calculator there? If your phone has got a calculator on it, do you need a calculator? Well, no, you don't. But I think our phones and these apps that still persist on desktop computers, they are the afterlife of the calculator. They are the calculator ascended to electronic heaven. The no longer exist in physical form is just their software. Their spirit lives on, but their actual body of the calculator has died off. Well, the calculator isn't existed, maybe obsolete, but I'm glad that the image that I am familiar with still lives on on my phone and my laptop.
其他所有地方消失了。我的意思是，如果你的收银机能算出总额，你还需要计算器吗？如果你的手机上有计算器，你还需要计算器吗？嗯，不需要。但我认为我们的手机和这些仍然存在于台式电脑上的应用程序，它们是计算器的来世。它们是升入电子天堂的计算器。它们不再以物理形式存在，只是软件。它们的精神长存，但计算器的实体已经消亡了。好吧，计算器可能已经过时了，但我很高兴我熟悉的形象仍然存在于我的手机和笔记本电脑上。
So thank you Keith so much. This is marvelous. It was so much fun to look back at this sort of nerdy history. Thanks. Not so. Thank you again for having me. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Lashma Dawn, mixed in tech production by Martin Gonzalez.
非常感谢 Keith。这太棒了。回顾这段书呆子历史真是太有趣了。谢谢。不客气。再次感谢你邀请我。本周的《99% Invisible》由 Lashma Dawn 制作，Martin Gonzalez 负责混音和技术制作。
Original music by our director of Sound Swan Real. Cady II is our executive producer, Kurt Colstad is the digital director, the rest of the team includes Delaney Hall, Chris Barube, Jason Dillion, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Jotson, Vivian Le, Jacob Moltenaro Medina, Kelly Prime, Joe Rosenberg, Gabriella Gladney, Sarah Baker,
原创音乐由我们的声音总监 Swan Real 创作。Cady II 是我们的执行制片人，Kurt Colstad 是数字总监，团队其他成员包括 Delaney Hall、Chris Barube、Jason Dillion、Emmett Fitzgerald、Christopher Jotson、Vivian Le、Jacob Moltenaro Medina、Kelly Prime、Joe Rosenberg、Gabriella Gladney、Sarah Baker，
and me Roman Mars. The 99% of his well- will logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. Special thanks to Keith Houston, go read his book, Empire of the Sum, The Rise and Rain of the Pocket Calculator. Also while you're on it, go read his other books too, shady characters, and the book, they're all so good any 99 PI fan will love them. We are part of the Stitcher and Sirius XM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building in beautiful Uptown
还有我 Roman Mars。《99% Invisible》的标志由 Stefan Lawrence 设计。特别感谢 Keith Houston，去读读他的书《Empire of the Sum, The Rise and Rain of the Pocket Calculator》。另外，在读的时候，也去读读他的其他书，《Shady Characters》和那本书，它们都非常好，任何 99 PI 的粉丝都会喜欢它们。我们是 Stitcher 和 Sirius XM 播客家族的一员，现在总部位于美丽的奥克兰上城区 Pandora 大楼以北六个街区，
Oakland, California Home of the Oakland Roots Soccer Club of which I am a proud community owner as other professional teams leave the Oakland Roots are Oakland first Always You can find the show on all the usual social media outlets You know where they are. You can find links to other Stitcher shows I love, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
加利福尼亚州奥克兰，奥克兰根基足球俱乐部（Oakland Roots Soccer Club）的所在地，我是该俱乐部的骄傲社区所有者。随着其他职业球队离开，奥克兰根基队永远是奥克兰的首选。你可以在所有常见的社交媒体平台上找到这个节目。你知道它们在哪里。你可以在 99PI.org 上找到我喜欢的其他 Stitcher 节目的链接，以及《99PI》的每一期往期节目。目前这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。